Was hältst du von Organspenden?
Find ich sinnvoll.
Ich bin Organspender.
Und auch schon seit langer Zeit.
Ich bin Organspender
tatsächlich.
Wenn du stirbst, würdest du dann deine Organe spenden?
Ja.
Wenn die brauchbar sind,
ja.
Ja, das bringt mir ja nichts mehr wenn ich Tod bin.
Hast du einen Organspenderausweis dabei?
Nein.
Ich hab den im Portemonnaie und das ist zu Hause.
Knochenmarksspende...
Aber ist nicht der Richtige...
Ok, wenn ich jetzt mit diesem Portemonnaie sterbe, bin ich kein Organspender.
Ausgedruckt und selbst zusammengeklebt.
Vorhin?
Ja.
Also ja, ich hatte bis vorhin keinen dabei, nein.
Weil ich ein neues Portemonnaie habe und da hat es nicht reingepasst.
Keine gute Ausrede, glaube ich.
Den hab ich noch nicht lange, aber seitdem immer bei mir.
Heute möchte ich mit euch mal über ein
Thema sprechen welches ich für sehr wichtig halte.
Aktuell warten in Deutschland ca.
9.000 Patienten auf ein Spenderorgan.
Es werden aber jedes Jahr nur ungefähr 1.000
Organe gespendet.
Jeden Tag sterben 3 Menschen, weil sie nicht
rechtzeitig ein Spenderorgan erhalten.
Letzte Woche, am 16.
Januar, hat sich der deutsche Bundestag gegen
einen Gesetzesentwurf entschieden, welcher
dafür gesorgt hätte, dass alle Bürger Organspender
werden, sofern sie keinen Widerspruch einlegen.
Das nennt man auch “Opt-Out”.
Man hat die Option auszusteigen, ist aber
erst mal automatisch drin und somit Spender.
Aktuell haben wir in Deutschland das Opt-In-
oder Zustimmungsverfahren: Man muss sich aktiv
melden und “Ja” sagen, um Spender zu werden.
Wie viele von euch habe ich mich darüber
aufgeregt, dass so entschieden wurde.
Es ist ja klar, dass in einem Opt-Out-System
viel mehr Menschen Spender wären.
Da s zeigen Statistiken wie diese hier.
Mit Opt-Out würde man also viele tausende
Menschenleben retten.
Aber dennoch bin ich mir nach einiger Recherche
gar nicht mehr so sicher, ob der Bundestag
nicht vielleicht doch richtig entschieden
hat.
Warum das so ist, darum geht es jetzt bei
Doktor Whatson.
Als allererstes sollte eins klar gemacht werden:
Dein Körper gehört dir.
Und nur du kannst eine Entscheidung darüber
treffen, ob du Organspender sein willst oder
nicht.
Das ist eine sehr persönliche und individuelle
Entscheidung, die jeder für sich ausmachen
muss und ich habe vollstes Verständnis dafür,
wenn man sich bewusst dagegen entscheidet.
Aus religiösen Gründen, weil man sich damit
nicht wohl fühlt; wieso auch immer.
Trotzdem sollte man informiert sein.
Um ein bekanntes Missverständnis direkt aus
dem Weg zu räumen: Viele Menschen machen
sich Sorgen, dass bei einer Organspende das
benötigte Organ zu früh entnommen werden
könnte und sie somit das eigene Leben kosten
könnte.
Das ist aber unmöglich.
Es ist erst möglich die Organe zu entnehmen,
wenn der Patient für Hirntot erklärt wurde.
Das bedeutet, dass es keine Möglichkeit mehr
für den Patienten gibt wieder zum Leben zu
erwachen.
Man ist definitiv unwiderruflich tot.
Im Falle eines klinischen Todes ist es zwar
in seltenen Fällen möglich wieder aufzuwachen,
hier ist es aber, genau deswegen nicht erlaubt
Organe zu entnehmen.
Auch die Angst, dass Ärzte einen früher
aufgeben und für Hirntod erklären, um die
Organe einem anderen Patienten geben zu können,
ist irrational.
Wenn ein Patient für Tot erklärt wird, müssen
das immer zwei Ärzte unabhängig voneinander
machen.
Die dürfen dann auch nicht bei der Entnahme
der Organe beteiligt sein und auch nicht entscheiden
, wer die Organe des Spenders bekommt.
Die Regeln hier sind sehr streng.
2003 haben Eric Johnson und Dan Goldstein
eine interessante Studie durchgeführt.
Manchen Teilnehmern der Studie haben sie gesagt,
dass der “Default”, also die Standardeinstellung,
sei, dass man Organspender ist.
Danach haben sie gefragt, ob die Teilnehmer
dem widersprechen möchten, um zu Nicht-Spendern
zu werden.
Andersherum haben sie anderen Teilnehmern
gesagt, dass diese standardmäßig keine Spender
wären, aber zustimmen könnten, um Spender
zu werden.
Wichtig ist, dass sich die Teilnehmer der
Studie mit der Problematik auseinandergesetzt
haben.
Es waren also informierte Entscheidungen,
die getroffen wurden.
Und dennoch: Der Standard, der Default, wie
die Forscher ihn nennen, hat einen riesigen
Einfluss auf die Entscheidung der Teilnehmer.
Noch interessanter: Eine dritte Gruppe Teilnehmer
konnte eine Entscheidung ohne Default treffen.
Ihnen wurde eine komplett neutrale Frage gestellt.
In dieser Gruppe fanden sich erstaunlicherweise
fast genauso viele Organspender, wie in der
Opt-Out-Gruppe, die widersprechen mussten.
In der echten Welt ist dieser Effekt noch
krasser.
In Deutschland besitzen ungefähr 36% der
Menschen einen Organspendeausweis, von denen
wiederum 72% zustimmen, dass sie ihre Organe
nach dem Tod spenden möchten.
In Österreich hingegen, wo das Widerspruchsverfahren
gilt, sind über 99% der Menschen Organspender.
Kaum jemand widerspricht hier.
Das ist der Effekt des Defaults.
An dieser Stelle würde mich mal von euch
interessieren, wie viele von euch einen  Organspendeausweis
haben und wie viele nicht.
Dazu gerne mal hier oben die Umfrage beantworten, die ich erstellt habe.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob die Doktor Whatson-Zuschauer
eher Organspender sind oder nicht.
Die Methode des Opt-Out-Verfahrens, wie es
in Österreich verwendet wird, kennt man allerdings
auch unter einem anderen Namen: Nudging.
Ein Nudge, also auf Deutsch ein Stups, ist
eine Methode, um das Verhalten von Menschen
zu beeinflussen.
Und zwar ohne Verbote, Gebote oder Bezahlung.
Ein gutes Beispiel hierfür sind Bilder auf
Zigarettenpackungen.
Um einen gesünderen Lebensstil zu fördern,
verpflichtet der Staat alle Zigarettenhersteller
die Packungen mit abstoßenden Bildern zu
versehen.
Die Idee: Wer wirklich Rauchen will, der kann
das immer noch tun, aber hoffentlich kann
man so einige Leute umstimmen.
Auch könnte man überlegen das gesunde Essen
in der Schulkantine weiter nach vorne zu stellen,
während die ungesunden Süßigkeiten schwieriger
zu erreichen sind.
Ok, das klingt erstmal ganz praktisch.
Man wird in die richtige Richtung geschupst.
Nur sehen Forscher, wie zum Beispiel Ralph
Hertwig vom Max-Planck-Institut für Bildungsforschung in Berlin,
die Gefahr dass Nudging ausarten kann.
Hinter dem Nudging steht ne gewisse Vorstellung, von psychologischer Entscheidungsforschung.
In der im Vordergrund steht, dass Menschen relativ schlecht sind wenn sie Entscheidungen treffen.
Und weil Menschen so viele Fehler machen und so schlecht sind,
lassen wir sozusagen einen Teil ihrer Entscheidungen, jetzt durch die Umwelt machen.
Das ist die Idee von der Entscheidungsarchitektur und die Umwelt stupst uns dann in die entsprechende Richtung.
Eine der Befürchtungen hier ist, das der Staat hier als paternalistischer Staat auftritt.
Also der Staat sagt:,, Hey du, ich weiß was gut für dich ist, du solltest Organspender sein!".
Und ich baue die Entscheidungsarchitektur so, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher ist, dass du auch Organspender wirst.
Es gibt Leute die argumentieren, dass Nudging immer am Rande von Manipulation entlang schlittert.
Der Unterschied zur Manipulation ist,
das der Stups ja immer auf ne Art und Weise sein sollte, das der Gestupste immer die Möglichkeit hat zu sagen:,,Nein, ich möchte das nicht".
Also der Organspender der zum Spender gemacht wird, aber die Möglichkeit hat zu sagen:,, Nein, ich möchte das nicht".
Und das ist der sogenannte libertäre Teil dieses Konstrukts.
Libertärer Paternalismus.
Das ist sozusagen die politische Philosophie die dahinter steht.
Halt die paternalistische Komponente und die Libertäre.
Menschliche Schwächen, Fehler und Defizite
könnten also ausgenutzt werden, um dich und
mich in eine Richtung zu nudgen.
In einem Opt-Out-System gilt: Jede Person,
die nicht widerspricht ist automatisch Organspender.
Da der Widerspruch mit Aufwand verbunden ist,
geht man davon aus, dass nur wenige Leute
widersprechen werden.
Aber das ist bevormundend.
Kritiker argumentieren, dass der Mensch so
als träges, faules Wesen angesehen wird,
das keine eigenen Entscheidungen treffen kann.
Viel sinnvoller wäre die Alternative zum
Nudging: Das Boosting.
Hierbei sollen die Kompetenzen der Menschen
verbessert werden.
Eine freie, informierte Entscheidung eines
mündigen Bürgers ist das Ziel.
In der Forschung von Eric Johnson und Dan
Goldstein konnte man sehen, dass auch das
funktioniert.
Wenn sich Menschen mit der Thematik auskennen
und selber eine Entscheidung treffen, dann
entscheiden sie sich fast genauso oft für
das Spenden von Organen, wie die Menschen
im Opt-Out-System.
Nur dass diese Menschen die Entscheidung selber
getroffen haben.
Ich denke das ist die Kernfrage dieser Diskussion:
Kann man Menschen zutrauen ihre eigenen Entscheidungen
zu treffen?
Klingt erst mal witzig.
Aber wenn man sich die Statistik ansieht, dann
kann man das scheinbar nicht.
Viel zu viele Leute sind zu faul den Default
zu ändern, der ihnen zugesprochen wird.
Wir hier in Deutschland sind zum Großteil keine Organspender,
weil es der Standard ist, dass man kein Organspender ist.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man nicht einfach
über die Köpfe der Menschen hinweg bestimmen.
Gut, kann man jetzt sagen: Das macht man ja
auch gar nicht.
Man kann sich immer noch bewusst dagegen entscheiden.
Aber Schweigen gilt nach deutschem Recht nicht
als Willenserklärung.
Menschen, die sich nicht äußern, sollten
weiterhin keine Spender sein.
Denn sonst wäre es ja auch keine Spende;
keine freiwillige Zuwendung ohne Gegenleistung.
Vor diesem Hintergrund finde ich die Entscheidung
des Bundestages nachvollziehbar.
Die Lösung des Problems sollte nicht sein
zu hoffen, dass sich möglichst wenige Menschen
die Mühe machen zu widersprechen.
Die Lösung sollte sein Menschen zu informieren
und sie selber eine Entscheidung treffen zu
lassen.
Das ist auch genau das was der Bundestag jetzt entschieden hat
Unteranderem,
eine neutrale Frage, die man zum Beispiel
das erste mal gestellt bekommt, wenn man seinen
Personalausweis bekommt.
Möchtest du Organspender sein, Ja oder Nein.
Mit Infos zum Thema Organspende und keinem
Druck von irgendeiner Seite.
Trotzdem ist das eine Menge Arbeit und wird
viele Jahre dauern.
Ein Opt-Out-System hätte jetzt sofort Menschenleben
gerettet.
Kann man das aufwiegen?
Viele Leute sagen, dass die 5 Minuten, die
es dauert um zu widersprechen in keinem Verhältnis
zu einem geretteten Menschenleben stehen.
Seht ihr das genauso?
Würde mich mal interessieren.
Auch das System mit dem Organspendeausweis
ist veraltet und funktioniert oft nicht.
Man kann ihn zum Beispiel verlieren oder die Schrift darauf ist nicht mehr lesbar.
Deswegen soll es in Zukunft ein Online-Portal
geben, auf dem man sich und seine Entscheidung
zur Organspende eintragen und jederzeit bearbeiten
kann.
Das kommt allerdings erst in einigen Jahren.
Deswegen: Wenn du kein Problem damit hast,
deine Organe nach deinem Tod zu spenden, dann
werde bitte Spender.
Besorg dir einen Organspendeausweis, zum Beispiel
kostenlos auf dieser Webseite hier, füll
ihn aus und steck ihn ins Portemonnaie.
Und sprich mit deinen Freunden und Verwandten
über das Thema, damit alle wissen, wie deine
Einstellung dazu ist.
Die wohl größte Errungenschaft der Demokratie
ist wohl die Freiheit über das eigene Schicksal
und den eigenen Körper entscheiden zu dürfen.
Ich persönlich kann mir nichts wichtigeres
vorstellen, als diese Freiheit zu nutzen,
um Menschenleben zu retten
Bei diesem Video gibts übrigens keine Sponsor, keiner gibt uns Geld dafür, dass wir das hier erzählen.
Es ist uns einfach nur wichtig darüber zu sprechen. Uns ist hier bei TwentyTwo aufgefallen, dass wir
zwar alle sehr große Fans von Organspenden sind,
aber nur die wenigsten von uns tatsächlich einen Organspendeausweis dabei haben.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt auf der Website die ich vorhin verlinkt habe,
6 Stück bestellt, wir werden die ausfüllen, wir werden die ins Portemonnaie stecken
und immer dabei haben, um Organspender zu sein.
Und wir hoffen möglichst viel von euch machen mit um
hoffentlich Leben zu retten.
Wie immer vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric!